vi ricordate qv opi quel gioco di
vecchissimo dove impersona vi una specie
di l'atleta olimpionico che tentava di
correre tentava allora siete pronti a
questo è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono famigerati per oggi
siamo su ragdoll runners che non faccio
manco tutorial credo ragazzi credo che
sia come vv ap quindi facciamo tipo di
10 metri poche come funziona quindi devo
farti posto è bello
cos'è sta roba accompagno solo come
funzionava datemi un tutorial qualcosa
c'era il tutorial a cerano a farmi cia
dal tutorial che all the right to push
with your light ed lag e google dire
uovo credo di aver capito ma è alquanto
un macello cioè mi chiama cioè che il
salse vabbè bello gravissimo bene questo
era il tutorial abbastanza semplice
adesso facciamo il resto facciamo anche
il multiplayer ragazzi provo io ce la
posso fare
by gravissimo beh dall'amica è la
madonna volo tipo superman
sono forte e ragazze vi sarà una figata
devi provare a vedere se riesco a fare
quello del massimo al massimo 100 metri
[Applauso]
cazzo
le porte che si arriva a questo è forte
dai già fatta dice che supero mi
chiamano superato
cosa stai facendo no vabbè ora fermi ma
anche al 50 metri idiota vai vai vai zio
ma zio vecchio zio perché era molto
molto sta succedendo sant'emidio cosa il
ciuccio il pollice quanti problemi
ok perfetto ripreso il via dai colori
figlio dai colori figlio mi chiedi se in
bolt danieli figlio vecchio di bio bio
veloce picchia 10 metri no non ci dona
non posso perdere così rega dai frate
non ci posso credere che arrivi alla
fine sempre non vinci
porca [ __ ] jam italia no vabbè ciao
come è accaduto a sta cosa
fatemi vedere un replay vi prego ma vi
rendete conto che tipo fino alla fine
sto per ora che [ __ ] c'erano occorso
un [ __ ] fino alla fine poi alla fine
ho vinto come ma come come ho fatto ho
vinto con la punta del naso tipo così
come saetta mcqueen
va bene credo di aver fatto facevo londi
jump visto che c'è anche il salto quanto
ormai abbiamo capito come funziona il
salto lo faccio con tasso giugno chi
cavolo volo volo me sì sì
mica che è stata fortissima questa
sembra lo zio bravo zio c660 c6 zio in
tempo record
ho fatto il record mino che va bene il
mio personal best gr grazie grazie
che bomba bellissima figlia che tecnica
60 metri ostacoli c'è anche quello
ostacoli non è perfetto michia vai forza
zio dimostra il tuo valore e poi vedere
quanto visto in volta in confronto a te
una merda bravo per bravis
ok adesso gli stesi tutti confondendoli
bravissimo adesso vai salta
no no deve saltare va bene va bene
importa al centro l'impresa di prossimo
davis alta ok a cosa fischiate non
capite un cazzo
questi non sanno neanche cosa vuol dire
correre fiscali e non lo dovevi
stenderlo tipo giù sino a prova bene è
sempre un'alternativa bravo no neanche
questo questo presentimento che abbiano
vinto è perché bravo
dai dai che spinge bene ho vinto io e
gli altri non sono stati capaci noi
ragazzi stavolta parto meglio quarto
meglio vai veloce veloce sono partito
bene soprattutto benissimo e poi
soprattutto su per bene vai vai vai
geova in selezionando sia veloce dai
biglietti staccati dai camion distaccati
bravo bravo noi che di recupera ma come
salvano problema non vale aronica sono i
poteri di ironman recupero come prima
zio con prima come prima il finale
[ __ ] arrivato secondo
pare però non è male pensavo peggio
adesso solo un secondo e mezzo in più
dell'altro dai ce la posso fare è
fattibile fattibile ok andrà benissimo
mica prima è andato meglio prima è
andato meglio prima è andato meglio per
attenzione attenzione niger nel cupero
bravissimo veloce veloce sento benissimo
bravo vai picchia allenamento reja in
queste doping e doping
no non ti fermare zio non ti fermare che
si è andato bene non ti fermare ti prego
non ti farò
non lo posso permettere non lo posso per
me qualcuno come ho fatto a fermarmi
alla fine
vabbè mica un professionista non mi
rallentare qui non miranda mandato
ammazzo ti ammazzo tra marzo quindi alle
minacce funzionano lega pro capite
rischiato di saltare anche secondo vai
frate va il frate impegnati in prepara
quello che fa anguilla impegnati ben by
zio ma porca [ __ ]
no è arrivato alla fine lo sapremo
[ __ ] lercia e velocissimo un fenomeno
quanto ci hanno messo di sé e bella
quanto tempo ci avete messo deficiente
distacco devastante fantastico va bè
ragazzi facciamo una roba facciamo tipo
multiplayer voglio vedere quanto riesco
a fare contro gli altri anche sono
contro il world record ragazzi diano che
cos'è vabbè come fai come ha fatto
quella fare sta roba secoli ha fatto il
record del mondo e ragazzo non saper
solo per dire come minchia fatta a
correre così c'è veramente al record del
mondo l'ha fatto così in tre secondi ci
ha messo che ci hanno messi e 865
io devo cercare di battere i record
mondiali o bene 100 me ma come pistorius
da battere il record mondiale va ai 100
metri
la partenza è buona la partenza è buona
il resto no l'ho fatto a fare otto
secondi di far fare in c bravo ci provo
[Applauso]
ogni batte per di veloce listarolo
dai veri figli dai cani più né ciao
vabbè longjumeau quello che ha battuto
il record del mondo di salto e una forte
spesa curioso più che altro
e vabbè è stato il guai il salto era
uguale zio
ok ok anche perfetto potrebbe essere un
problema non sapere come si salta nel
salto in lungo
porca [ __ ] cosa ho fatto
va bene un fenomeno va bene così ok 60
metri perfetto sono online ragazzi ad
abbatterlo vai sono tutti scarsi con la
morte sul mio forte sono forte io
madonna che veloce 5 secondi il record
era di 3 secondi e mica al tizio ancora
indietro ciao ciao fra però sei stato
bravo la film contro atleti a training
ma cazzo queste forte queste forte ma ti
faccio un culo cosi chi pensi di butter
no vorrei figli i figli lo ri bigli fra
the flat e faccio trovare la figlia a
casa è vedi come al richiamo della [ __ ]
tutti vincono porca eva come ti ho fatto
il culo quando sfidate online fa vige è
partita un'altra sono contro scout
no non ho che te li pigliano che si
pigliano chiatri pigna culi sono contro
uno che si chiama e ascom non vale la
penalità non vale
non vale la pena l'italia arbitro pugno
non vale mi stava lanciando una scarpata
farò prima o poi moving 233 muori niente
ma regalano disco a partire i 10 metri
ma questo può parte non c'è un problema
di fondo pai osla io non lo sono
dimenticato doveva partire va bene va
bene forse sei cava i sedimenti cazzo
celino ma perché tanta l'altro è lento
veniva bene è rimasto lì fermo va beh
ryan 080 proviamoci questa l'iniziativa
di voler battere chi pensi ok attento ai
tiri figli attento atipica velocissimo
dolcissimo pochissimo
non è vero mi chiamo scontro tra titani
effetto era andato sempre più veloce
prima ma ho vinto sempre io sucate mila
minchia tutti quanto sta facendo
ho deciso di diventare una ballerina
direi che possono chiudere qui un
episodio di ragazzo si chiamava sto
gioco non mi ricordo va bene così è
stato al corto strano di giocare un
qualcosa simile aqp perché mi sono
ricordato il perché avevo smesso di
giocarci perché forse non ha troppo
senso comunque ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto spero che abbiate imparato come
si corre se il video è piaciuto molto il
tracciato momento è un mi piace anche a
pagani facebook e con in utah tale
descrizione sergio reti di sederi ci
mettiamo a una prossima corsa
olimpionica della vita
beh ragazzi
[Musica]